I'm usually the life of the party at these
Christmas parties. But tonight all I want to
do is hide. I feel like everyone here saw my
mom's interview where she basically said
that I'm having trouble conceiving.
You have got to help me.
What? You have to help me.
What happened? Ever since I've been miced,
all I have done is say the most terrible
things.
That's great.
I already called her out about it, but I'm
not going to bring it up again since it's
Christmas.
Just a bummer, because it just makes me feel
like I can't trust her right now.
I just want to look in the mirror really
quick.
You smell like a rat.
Thanks.
Let's go.
Okay. I brought Kim with me.
Hi, honey. Hi, sexy.
Yes. Over here.
When's the baby?
When you gonna have a baby? Beginning of
next. Not beginning, but soon.
Like, wanted to enjoy the first year.
The reason I said what I said on E!
I keep getting asked when she have a baby.
When is she? And I was so sick of hearing
this. And I know that she went and did these
IVF things.
You say you want to have a child and
everything, where's the bump?
Did you ask Paris about it?
When we are together or we're talking, we
don't necessarily talk about IVF or whatever
you call it. She'll say it very casually,
like, I got to be down in Santa Monica
because I'm going into and we move on to
something else.
How's everything? Really good.
Any baby? Chad doesn't look like baby.
No, no. Yeah.
Next year, year of marriage.
I'm terrified.
Tell her it's not that scary because she's
really scared about it. It's actually
scarier later.
To do it later.
I just don't want to do it at all.
Get a surgeon.
Everyone's asking me, when are you going to
have a baby? Right now, I just want to be in
a cozy bubble at home.
Just have such anxiety.
The girls want to say hi to you.
The heater on in here, Lola.
And I'm going to turn down and Sam Sheen.
We turn the heat off. Make them feel good.
Marry Christmas. Since like five years old.
I haven't seen you in so long.
Christmas, Christmas.
Wait. Look at your little shoes.
Cute. So cute.
Those shoes are so cute.
Sup!
I had to get away for a second and breathe.
I feel like I've been in front of the
Christmas tree the entire party.
I'm like, now I understand how Santa Claus
feels. Oh, I got a call today from the
cloning people.
Cloning people?
Yeah, but for Diamond Baby.
What? I'm getting a clone of her.
Do you have diamond babies?
Stem cells? Yes.
From when she got fixed, I had them keep the
cells just in case something like this
happened.
Call me old fashioned, but the way I grew up
is we have a pet and we love them.
And it passes and we bury it in the
backyard. So this concept of cloning is a
little strange.
It's very on brand for her.
So, yeah, I guess.
I saw your whole new baby clothing line.
Did you bring any for me, dear?
No. What?
No. I've been shopping for years for these
kids.
Like mom. There's so much
stuff I have like, literally my storage unit,
probably. I don't even know how many.
Containers of baby things.
Containers? Lots.
Like, my storage unit is the size of Costco.
It's.
I believe that.
So I get nervous. Like having a family next
year. Like, I literally am nonstop.
Like, how do you have time for it all?
There's no breaks.
I'm so tired.
And I just got an email from my doctor that
the embryos are girls.
For you or the dog?
Me?
Yeah. Do you have, like, babies rooms and
stuff? Because I was at your house today and
all I saw was sunglasses rooms, closets,
storage, racks, more racks purse room.
Those are my other babies.
We've literally kept this baby secret from
all the people that work out of my house.
So I couldn't even have decorated his
nursery if I wanted to, because then that
would give it away.